there is a giant cloud in space hundreds
of light years away from the Earth
with some of its areas concealing dozens
of yet unborn Stars others are ripped
apart by tremendous flashes
the space here is permeated by lethal
ionizing radiation and threads of red
hot hydrogen
and fiery vortices are capable of
absorbing whole Stellar systems
This Is Where Stars Are Born a stellar
Nursery Which is closest to the earth
what does it conceal from us
[Music]
there are Stellar nurseries richly
scattered across the Galaxy with some of
them comparatively modest in size
others stretch for tens and even
hundreds of light years these are vast
nebulae made up of interstellar gas and
dust being inexorably compressed by
gravity forces most of these tremendous
clouds are barely visible against the
abyss of space but some of them can be
seen from the earth with a naked eye
[Music]
one of these structures is the Orion
Nebula located
1344 light years away from the earth it
is the middle object in the so-called
sword of Orion
clearly visible line produced by three
relatively bright light sources due to
its large size and comparative closeness
to the Earth the nebula has been
attractive for scientists ever since the
early days of astronomy
it is hardly surprising therefore that
this great structure is one of the best
studied space objects
it was the Hubble orbital Space
Telescope that beamed back first images
of the Orion Nebula back in 1993 where
the rich diversity of its colors can be
appreciated
most of the material was of a reddish or
bluish purple Hue while unusual bright
green lines of some peripheral areas
were revealed by spectral analysis
this phenomenon perplexed scientists for
a long time as the observed radiation
did not demonstrate any chemical element
known at the time
there was even a hypothesis that was put
forward about there being a hypothetical
element nebulum argued to be not present
on our planet but allegedly amply
scattered across clouds and space
however with the advancement of science
it turned out that the light was emitted
by extremely rarefied and dionized
oxygen this discovery accounted not only
for the bizarre illumination of many
nebulae including our sun
there are currently not less than 3 000
stars discovered in the Orion Nebula to
date as well as giant clouds of
interstellar gas and a great number of
protostars
all this amazing diversity of space
objects is concentrated in an area of
around 23 light years in diameter all of
them continuously and elaborately
interacting with each other
the overall mass of the material
concentrated here is around 10 000 solar
masses
looking at the Orion Nebula closer
we will notice several clearly defined
areas the most outstanding of them is
trapezium also known as Theta 1 orionis
it's an open star cluster about 300 000
years of age made up of eight main
components
some of them are binary Stars others
have no companions
the brightest and most noticeable the
trapezium stars are four Stellar systems
designated by letters of the Latin
alphabet
located close to each other they lie
within an area about one and a half
light years in diameter
each of these objects mass is within 15
to 40 solar masses which means that
these stars are quite young and hot
Theta 1 orionis C is the most massive as
well as the brightest star in both the
trapezium cluster and actually the
entire nebula it is a white and blue
main sequence star with a mass roughly
40 solar masses whose radius is eight
times that of the Sun the object's
surface temperature is approximately 45
000 Kelvin and its Luminosity about 250
000 times higher than that of the Sun
the radiation of theta 1 orionis C
illumines virtually all the nebula
around it but there is hardly any
Interstellar gas in its immediate
vicinity
this is the case due to the fact it is
typical for objects of this class to
experience exceptionally powerful
Stellar Wind that scatters rarified
material far off
having traveled a few light years away
from trapezium we will see another
remarkable system which is Theta 2
orionis
it is made up of three gravitationally
bound stars located close to the
so-called Orion bar an extensive feature
of hot gas emitting bright light it was
impossible to study this area for a long
time on account of dense clouds of dust
and thanks to the James Webb Telescope
more detailed images of this region have
been beamed back to us
the first component of theta 2 orionis
is just slightly less massive and not as
luminous as the trapezium's biggest star
as for its surface temperature it
measures about 35
000 Kelvin
the second component of the system is 15
times as massive as the sun and 12 000
times as bright
third component is as heavy as five
solar masses and its temperature almost
reaches 14 000 Kelvin however it wasn't
just bright stars that called the
researchers attention
James Webb's infrared cameras allowed it
to detect previously unseen objects
hidden deep within the clouds of gas and
dust
thanks to the telescope about 180
so-called prop Lids have been discovered
at the heart of the Orion Nebula these
are dense dark protoplanetary disks
surrounding stars that are still in the
process of formation one of these is
Orion
294-606 a young protostar about 1
million years old surrounded by a gas
and dust disc about 300 astronomical
units in diameter
thanks to its being air John to Earth we
can observe its structure and size
it is expected to hit the main sequence
phase in a few million years and it will
be accompanied by a sister of several
exoplanets and possibly their satellites
the night sky of these future celestial
bodies must be a truly fantastic site
just imagine a multi-colored luminous
veil with a glow of a multitude of close
and bright stars far more numerous than
those seen from the earth coming through
and now and then tremendous swirls of
glowing gas cover half the sky
turning the Knight into translucent
Twilight
if we fly a little further and examine
the wider region we see that the bulk of
the nebula is filled with scattered gas
the central part of the cloud is filled
with highly ionized hydrogen which
actively absorbs high energy Stellar
radiation
the temperature of this gas can reach 10
000 Kelvin but it falls sharply towards
the edge of the region
temperature and pressure contrasts as
well as the Collision of Stellar Wind
streams set material in space in motion
creating tremendous currents and
vortices
according to calculations some of them
can reach speeds of up to 50 kilometers
per second and their size can be greater
than the solar system
also in some areas of the nebula thin
strands stretching for several light
years have been detected consisting of
relatively cool molecular hydrogen
without mixtures of methane ethane and
water
further out we will see that the central
region of the Orion Nebula is enveloped
in a vast cloud of cooler denser gas
The Cloud of bright stars and the
luminescence of ionized hydrogen
intricately intertwined here creating a
beautiful multi-colored curtain of light
hidden behind it are hundreds of space
objects invisible in the optical range
but the infrared cameras of today's
telescopes allow us to see through the
veil of interstellar Mata
by combining data from different sources
astronomers have discovered about 700
protostars at different stages of
evolution within this region
their concentration is noticeably lower
than in the central part of the nebula
due to the lower degree of gravitational
compression of the interstellar gas
the absolute majority of these objects
are very young by space standards and
are still in the process of formation
according to Modern concepts of Stellar
evolution new stars formed during
gradual gravitational compression of
large clouds of interstellar gas
typically as a result of this process
giant nebulae split up into a number of
closely grouped gravity centers which
soon turn into protostars
such clusters are called Stellar
nurseries or more scientifically regions
of star formation
at a certain point the internal pressure
of the compressed gas compensates for
the gravitational forces bringing the
protostar to a state of temporary
equilibrium
the remaining material swirls into a
giant Vortex disc with some of it
gradually absorbed by the future star
and the rest of it by contrast expelled
far beyond the boundaries of the nascent
system
the growing magnetic field of the young
star also plays its part
as ionized particles accelerate through
its field lines and then rapidly escape
from the vicinity of the object
it has been calculated that such flows
can reach speeds of up to several
hundred kilometers per second
as they collide with the gas cloud
surrounding them they create large-scale
vortices and hemispheres called herbig
Harrow objects
in the process part of the kinetic
energy dissipates into light and heat
giving these bizarre structures
different colors
in addition the ultra fast motion
affects the surrounding material
spreading shock waves across it which
incidentally are also captured by
telescopes
since Stellar nurseries contain many
closely spaced protostars each producing
several gas emissions it is not
surprising that herbig Harrow objects
exhibit an amazing variety of shapes and
colors clearly being essentially the
result of a major Cosmic Collision
they're highly unstable and variable
her big Harrow objects rapidly change
color and shape and typically disperse
completely over several tens of
thousands of years
during this time they cover between one
and three light years on an escape
trajectory from their parent Stars about
400 such objects have been discovered so
far with their total number within the
Milky Way estimated to be about one
hundred and fifty thousand
perhaps one of the varieties of this
awe-inspiring natural phenomenon is the
bullets hundreds of astronomical units
and diameter also detected in the Orion
Nebula moving at incredible speeds they
easily Pierce thinner hydrogen clouds
creating far-flung shock waves in them
according to spectral analysis the
frontal parts of these objects contain
atoms of iron that glow in the infrared
the bullets are estimated to be about a
thousand years old and their origin is
still a mystery they supposedly
originated from some catastrophic event
moving on we will soon find that the
Orion Nebula is part of a much larger
Cosmic structure called the Orion cloud
stretches for hundreds of light years
accounting for virtually the entire
constellation of Orion in the earth's
night sky
this is why the well-known Horsehead
nebula is located remarkable for its
bizarre shape
it is a dense dust cloud about three and
a half light years in diameter clearly
visible against background or
contrasting Scarlet glow also close to
the Orion Nebula there is an impressive
Cosmic structure called the Barnard's
Loop this emission nebula about 300
light years in size came into being
about 3 million years ago after a series
of consecutive explosions of mutually
close supernovae
after the shock compressed gas jets
mixed together they produced a gigantic
curved nebula and the glow of several
young Stars gathered in an open cluster
made it reddish in hue
for all its beauty the Orion Nebula is a
fragile and unstable object by the
universe's standards Stellar winds and
pressure of light from many young stars
as well as gas emissions and turbulent
vortices constantly disperse its
material in the surrounding space the
nebula has already lost about 60 percent
of its original material and in about a
hundred thousand years it will be
stripped of its remnants
in place of the shiny multi-colored
Cloud there will remain an open star
cluster similar to the Pleiades
for a Time the young Stars forming it
will move together but eventually each
will find its separate way through the
vast expanse or the boundless Galaxy
around
even a spite of the long years of
observation equipment modernization
James Webb has clearly demonstrated that
we still haven't seen the universe in
all its diversity thanks to the images
from the telescope we found that even
allegedly well studied areas of the
Starry Sky may prove to Harbor new
amazing things to discover
the dark depths of space can seal
countless Mysteries who knows what we're
to see there tomorrow
[Music]